شخصيه مميزه من بيروت ينضم الينا مراسل
مساء العربيه محمود شكر ومعه مفاجاتنا على
مائده الافطار النجم راغب علامه اهلا بكم
اهلا محمود واهلا بالسيفرستار راغب
بالعيله الكريمه يسعد هالمسا
مساء الخير مساء الخير
[موسيقى]
والله ناقصه وجودكم يكون معنا هون ببيروت
ببيروت الجميله تسلم بيروت الروعه وبيروت
الجريحه بس بيروت دائما بتضل واقفه وبتضل
اجمل واجمل يا راغب واكيد في ناس مثلكم
اللي بتبثوا لروح الحلوه وخصوصا على
الطاوله تفضلي يا محمود
الزملاء ايضا المشاهدين في لبنان وفي
العالم العربي
وساذهب سريعا الى سوبر ستار راغب علامه
راغب اليوم في هذا المساء على اي توقيت
بدك تفطرنا على توقيتهم على توقيتك او على
توقيتنا على التوقيت مين على توقيت ربنا
سبحانه وتعالى ربنا اللي اقوى من الظلم
واقوى من الظالمين
واقوى من الخونه بلبنان يلي خربوا هالبلد
واللي ما زالوا يعني
يعملوا جهد انه يخربوا اكثر شيء قبل ما
يمشوا لانه ظاهر انه نهايته قريبه
ربنا مش حيسامحهم على اللي عملوه راغب هون
بقضيه التخريب يعني باليومين الماضيين انت
تبعت وايضا انا لن ادخلك باي محور من
المحاور ولكن كان في هنالك شيء كبير جدا
اللبنانيه منهم من قال توقيتنا توقيتهم
مناطقنا مناطقهم
حضارتنا تخلفهم عقارب الساعه لربما ذهبت
بالساعه الى 89 جاليري سمعان والمتحف انت
كفنان هيك مرهف رواق واليوم شهر رمضان
وبدايه العشر الاوائل وبعدين نسيت انه انا
ابدا كذلك واعذروني لاننا لسنا على طاوله
فقط بل على طاوله السيده جهاد التي هي
ايضا بقيت تصرف على هذه المائده بحوالي
ثلاثه ارباع ساعه وبالاضافه الى مجموعه من
الاصدقاء منهم ايضا من حضر من القاهره
ومنهم ايضا من هو شقيق دراغب هو مدير
اعماله وايضا اصدقائنا لذلك اعود اليك
ارغب ماذا تنصح هؤلاء
من
هؤلاء الذين حاولوا ان ياخذون الى الى
الوراء
مش بشر والله مش بشر لو بشر ما بيعملوا
هيك الدنيا رمضان انت ما شفت الضياع اللي
عشنا فيه ضيعنا حتى التليفون مع الساعه
بطل مربوط التلفون بقول لك الساعه سبعه
الساعه بتقول لك الساعه سته بس ما حسيت
اتشلعت هيك العلاقات الاجتماعيه هو انا
انا بالنسبه الي شفتها من منظار اخر
هولي بسياسه بلبنان بيعملوا بزته فقاعه
عشان يمرقوا
مؤامراتهم او صفقاتهم
ما بعرف شو تبقى من لبنان شو تبقى
بالخزينه شو تبقى بعد من من الخير ومن
الاخلاق
بحكم اوصل لبنان والشعب اللبناني
الى مرحله
يعني لا توصف لا توصف يعني
يعني المفروض الحاكم العادل وعم نشوفها
بدول الخليج
حاكم العادل يلي هو كل همه صعبه
اسعاد شعبه بالامارات حتى عملوا بطاقه
اسعاد للناس انت
اسعاد وزاره السعاده اليوم بالمملكه
العربيه السعوديه هيدا التوجه اللي صار
على يدي
[موسيقى]
ببلدهم الثاني الامارات العربيه المتحده
وتحت حكم انبل الناس واشرف الناس جيهان
انا سعيد سعيد بقدر بقدر بالمي لانه على
سفره رمضان مش عم شوفوا اولادي قديش هيدا
بياثر بقدر سعادتي بانهم يعرفوا اللي
اختاروا يعيشوا وعرفوا كيف يقرروا
المستقبلهم وين يعيشوا بامان
ويكونوا اشخاص فعلين بالمجتمع مثل ما اردت
الدوله الاماراتيه ان يكون الناس اللي
عندهم فاعلين بالمجتمع اليوم لؤي عم
بيتنقل بين الامارات ولندن وامريكا
لانه لاي طبيعه درسه عم يدرس الفاشن عم
يدرس المجوهرات
في كثير بمجال الفاشن سواء بعده عم يتنقل
بين اوروبا وامريكا
انت وجيهان وانا يعني شو عنا بالحياه
اليوم غير انه نسعدهم يعني انا اليوم
اعتبرني حاكم بقلب هالبيت حاكم عادل بدي
اسعد شعبي كيف عم تكسر على جيهان بهالايام
هيك اللي هيك الروحانيه الهادئه اللي فيها
العبادات اللي فيها هيك هدوء النفس انك
بتلاقي بالبيت مثلا هلا نحن كنا اصدقاء بس
انه وين صعبه كيف عم تتعاطف اليوم اليوم
نحن على تواصل مع الاولاد كل نهار وبعدين
جيهان يعني الحمد لله الله رزقني بسيده
صالحة
بقمه
محمود احنا كمان عنا كتير اسئله ودردشه
والحمد لله عم نتواصل مع اولادنا
انه الحلقه الاولى او الفقره الاولى انتهت
ونحن كمان ايضا بدنا نفطر لانه كما اثرت
جيهان اشتغلت ثلاث اربع ساعات راح نعطيكم
مجال تفطروا على رواق
والدردشه مستمره معكم على هالجلسه الحلوه
ودائما اجمل ما في شهر رمضان شهر الفضيل
هي لمه العائله والاصدقاء على طاوله
معنا والعيله الكريمه شكرا جزيلا حيكونوا
معنا باخر الحلقه اكيد في فقرتنا المسائيه
رمضانيه افطار مع نذهب اليوم الى لبنان
والى حاله غنائيه يصعب تكرارها ونجاح
مستمر وممتد على مدار اكثر من اربعه عقود
السوبر ستار راغب علامه في رصيده مجموعه
كبيره من الاغاني والالبومات والجوائز
ومشاركاتك عضو لجنه التحكيم في برامج
الهوات مزج اللون الشعبي بالرومانسي وقدم
مختلف اللهجات وتربع على عرش قلوب جمهوره
اسمه اصبح اشهر من نار على العلم واليوم
هو ضيفنا في مساء العربيه على مائده
الافطار اللبنانيه السوبر ستار راغب علامه
ونرحب اذا مجددا بسوبر ستار راغب علامه
نذهب معكم الى بيروت ومن منزل النجم راغب
علامه انا بس بدي اتطمن انه خلصته اكل ما
كنا ازعجناكم من اول الساعه بالاول
ما في ازعاج ابدا بالعكس بالعكس اهلا
وسهلا نورت وشرفتوا بيتكم اكيد احنا كتير
سعداء بوجودك معنا وكمان بلغ تحياتنا للست
جيهان واعجابنا فيها وبجمالها كمان
الله يخليك شكرا وهي بتسلم عليكم هلا هي
قاعده مع الضيوف معلش هلا بعد شوي اليوم
يطير بيعنيك خصوصا فيما يتعلق مساله
العائله ولمة الاصدقاء والاهل
يعني رمضان هذا العام ولا العام اللي قبله
ولا اللي بعده هو الشهر الفضيل هو شهر
الخير والمحبه والعطاء والمساعده
بنعيشه بكل فتره كل كل سنه بنعيشه
بالطريقه اللي المفروض ربنا امرنا وطلب
منا انه نعيش هذا الشهر الفضيل بهذه
الطريقه لكن المفارقه الوحيده
المزعج كنا حكينا شوي انا واستاذ محمود
انه اليوم بوضع لبنان
بفرق العائلات عن بعضها يعني انا اولادي
مضطرين يكونوا باسراره جامعاتهم بكثير
شباب وصبايا التروي يغادروا البلد الظروف
الصعبه لانه هم بفتره بده يامنوا حياتهم
يامنوا مستقبلهم وطبعا احنا ربينا اولادنا
انه لا يكونوا متابعين لكل هذه
المجموعات اللي دمرت لبنان ربيناهم على
محبه الانسان على محبه رب العالمين على
اطاعه رب العالمين ربيناهم على الخير
والمحبه والعطاء وليس على الاذى
والتكسير والحروب
اسمحلي راغب يعني كل العالم بيعرف لبنان
لبنان لا يموت لبنان هو عنوان الامل
والتفاؤل لكل شعوب العالم وشعوب العربيه
بالتالي كلنا امل في لبنان وبالشعب
اللبناني ان ينهضوا دائما الرغم كل
العثرات والحروب اللي مضت عليهم لانه
دائما بثبتوا انه الامل والتفاؤل والحب هو
عنوان الشعب اللبناني هذا هذا ثانيا اليوم
كمان اكيد
كلامك كلامك مليون بالمئه لبنان عطاء من
رب العالمين الجمال اللي الله اعطانا اياه
بهذا البلد انا اللي درت الكره الارضيه لم
اشاهده باي بلد في العالم يعني في كثير
ناس استجابه على لبنان بتشوف بيروت ويمكن
برمانه او فاريا وما بيعرفوا لبنان على
حقيقته لبنان بلد جنه على الارض لم يستطيع
الاشرار قتله لكن الاشرار استطاعوا ان
يبعدوا للاوادم يبعدوا الشباب
يعني عرفت كيف طبعا احنا كنا نتمنى انه كل
كل الناس الشعب
اتمنى انه نشوف الشعوب العربيه دائما عم
تيجي لانه لبنان هو الطفل المدلل عند
العالم العربي اليوم لما بنشوف لبنان
اخوته من العالم العربي مش عم يقدروا يجوا
هيدا شي بوجعنا كمان مثل ما اولادنا بعده
اهلنا
بعيدا عن الوجع وبعيدا عن الحزن يعني راغب
علامه بعد كلها سنين بعد اول اغنيه له كيف
يشعر اليوم بعد مرورها سنين بنفس النجوميه
يحظى فيها نفس الجماهيريه وحب الجمهور هذا
يظهر بعد كل اغنيه صدرها وبعد كل حفله
تحياها نفس الجمال كمان
انا انا
سيدتي انا بعد كل حفله اظن واعتقد واعيش
بانه هاي
اول حفله اللي جايه هي اول حفله في حياتي
وبعد كل اغنيه بقدمها بشعر انه هيدي اول
اغنيه في حياتي عم اقدمها انا زلمه عندي
طموح لا اشبع من حب الناس لم ولن اشبع من
حب الناس ولن اشبع من خلق
وتقديم اغاني جديده وانا اليوم بدوي هلا
عم بحكيكن انا كل النهار بالاستديو وهلا
بعد الافطار جينا نفطر ونطل هذا اللقاء
اللي بعتز اني طليت معكم فيه كمان رايح
على الستديو لكمل شغلي لحتى احضر اغاني
للمواسم اللي جايه
بس بدنا نسال هيك اسئله شخصيه نعرف الوجه
الاخر لراغب بما انه عسيره رمضان شو الطبق
الرمضاني المفضل او الاكله المفضله عند
راغب شو الحلو المفضل مثلا عندك
الحلو المفضل هو الكلاج
وطبق المفضل هو الفتوش
هل في كتير لو ما في فتوش بتحسي انه مكانه
ما كانه شهر رمضان انا لازم انه عروس
السفره هي الفتوش
الله يعين الناس
ونساعد على قد ما بنقدر ايدنا توصل للناس
لكن بدل الادبا وصلنا يعني مثلي والاف
الناس لبنانيين وغير لبنانيين عم بساعدوا
يعني الناس المحتاجين بهالبلد لكن هذا
الوضع مقلق
ومبكي حقيقه طيب
بعد شوي شو الاغنيه الاقرب لقلب راغب
علامه وشو السير اتقانوا لاكثر من اللهجه
اكثر من لهجه انه الله اعطاني القدره
ربنا اعطاني القدره اني اتقن غناء اللهجات
ونحن ربينا في يعني ببيتنا الوالد الله
يرحمه والوالده كنا دائما كانوا يدقوا عود
ويغنوا مثل ما يغنوا للسيده فيروز
وديع الصافي يغننه ليغنوا للسيده ام كلثوم
وعبد الحليم حافظ
موسيقى الاجيال عبد الوهاب يعني حقيقه ان
احنا على هذه اللهجات فما بحسها غريبه عني
وانا كابن بيروت يعني انا انا بيروتي
من منطقه الغبيره
هذه المنطقه ساحل الجنوبي يلي قريبه من كل
العالم حتى مطار بيروت بسحل الجنوبي يعني
يعني هو نقطه التواصل مع العالم
فهذه بتساعد الاقرب
والله بضيع ما بعرف نسيم الدنيا ولا يا
ريت في خبيها ولا قلبي
ولا شو
حلو ولا توام روحي ولا مغرم يا ليل ولا
استماره سته ولا اللي باعنا خسر دلعنا ولا
بابا يعني عدد الاغنيات اللي نزلتها
احيانا صدقا احيانا اشعر وانا على المسرح
كانه القديم هو جديد
نورتنا شكرا جزيلا لك